[Music]
something like this looks like complete
science-fiction that's at least decades
away but augmented reality contact
lenses might be closer on the horizon
than you might think wow that is
incredible heart rate data speed and
even with your eyes shot you will be
able to see this because it's lit up and
obviously the lens is sitting beneath
your eyelid it feels seriously sci-fi on
the fall of 2015
three Silicon Valley veterans with two
of them having bad eyesight formed a
secret a start-up under the cover name
cactus while they worked in stealth mode
not knowing if what they were doing
would even be feasible and as the years
went by they recruited talent from Apple
Amazon HP Google and more to invent
something that had never been built
before
using technology that was said to have
to be called in from the future fast
forward to January 2020 and the tech
this team came out of stealth mode under
their new name mojo a start-up with over
a hundred million dollars in funding
that promises to elevate humanity's
vision with the world's first augmented
reality contact lenses as a new player
in the trillion-dollar cyborg revolution
ar has been around for a while now so
it's not anything special we've seen
things like Google glass that can be
extremely useful but AR has never really
taken off probably because people don't
want to look like dorks walking around
wearing something like that
that's where mojo Vision claims to come
in they've created the world's first
real smart contact lenses that's able to
display useful heads-up information onto
your vision without having something
obtrusive like Google glass they're
calling this new form of tech invisible
computing an albeit cheesy marketing
term that really just means instead of
computers being a separate bulky tool
that gets in the way of your day-to-day
life it seamlessly integrates into your
lifestyle it's there when you need it
hands-free and you can forget that even
exists when you don't need it right now
their focus is helping people with
different vision impairments see better
by overlaying images over their vision
zooming in on objects enhancing objects
in their field of view and other stuff
like that this one really hits home for
me personally because I have a really
weak left eye so most of my vision is
perceived through my right eye with my
left really only serving as peripheral
vision something like this could
possibly change all that and allow me to
see the world in a whole new perspective
without evasive expensive and scary eye
surgery but there are others who aren't
fortunate as me and have much more
impaired vision and what's something
like mojo or other startups you can
imagine that humanity's future will
probably look a lot clearer
but it doesn't stop there because in the
future their goal is to make the lives
of everyday people like you and I a
little bit easier a little bit safer and
a little bit more convenient for example
instead of having to look down at your
phone for navigation instructions and
thus taking your eyes off the road your
next turn would be overlaid onto the
road in the real world meaning that in
the future I can potentially finally
play me for speed or min.that Club in
real life and options with how AR lenses
can help us in our day-to-day lives are
really endless night vision weather new
text messages translation notifications
for your phone health metrics like heart
rate fun stuff like learning about new
constellations in the sky as you're
looking at it
helping fighter fighters see inside
burning buildings and much more that is
the power of this new industry that mojo
neuro-link and other stars are
participating in that I'm Corning the
cyborg revolution see humans have
different levels of needs that need to
be fulfilled in a certain order and
every business works within these
different levels the first level of
needs are physiological needs things
that we need to stay alive air food
water shelter sleep clothing all that
good stuff
the next need is our need for safety our
personal safety safety of employment
health property etc and the following
levels after that or more high-level
concepts that are nice to haves but
wouldn't really matter all that much if
you were out on the street hungry cold
and jobless and those are love esteem a
self-actualization this is what's called
Maslow's hierarchy of needs and
ambitions the lower on the hierarchy of
needs that you're serving to your
customers the more evergreen and the
more bulletproof your industry is going
to be during a recession or a depression
people probably aren't going to be going
out and paying their hard-earned money
for escape rooms expensive avocado toast
or indoor trampoline parks but they'll
probably still buy toilet paper if
you're blind or you damage your eyes and
an accident you're probably still gonna
be more inclined to do business with a
company like mojo even if money is tight
and this is what I love about companies
like mojo they're pushing the boundaries
of what's possible with humanity by
improving the bottleneck of the
in between our archaic biological bodies
and the outside world and the way they
achieve this is by providing a new
solution to such a basic level human
need such as eyesight to be able to make
what's basically a microcomputer inside
of a contact lens they've had to invent
everything from scratch the bread and
butter of the device is the world's
smallest and densest micro LED display
that contains 77,000 pixels in the size
of a grain of sand this micro display is
then positioned in the contact lens in a
way to mainline its light towards a tiny
part of your retina that can see the
light the best which is an indented area
in the back of your eye called the fovea
and because it's a small grain of sand
size object that close to your eye you
hardly see the physical display while
wearing it from there though 77,000
pixels are used to display all that
important information we talked about in
a night vision looking green hue along
with the display all the other
components needs to make it work we'll
also be housed in the contact lens
itself including a computer processing
chip an image sensor a tiny day long
battery and in the future the contact
will include other cool tech like an eye
tracking sensor communications chip and
maybe it will even be able to be power
wirelessly from an external wearable
that you wear around your neck since
it's a contact lens after all if you
already have an eye prescription that
prescription could be built into the
contact lens itself so that you get the
benefits of both regular contact lenses
and smart ones and just like regular
contact lenses you put it in in the
morning and then you take it out a night
into a cleaning case that also charges
it much like an air pods case it's a
contact lens you put it in your eye in
the morning and you take it out at night
and we try to provide value to you
throughout the day when you take it out
at night you put it into a cleaning case
that also charges the batteries it's
very comfortable it fits jiraiya
corrects your vision when you wear it so
if you have a prescription we build the
prescription into the lens
although the progress mojo has made in
just five years is pretty insane
there's still a long road ahead for them
currently they've tested all those micro
components including the sensor and CPU
outside of the lens and all that's left
to get a fully independent contact lens
is to fit it all together they're very
far from going on sale to the average
consumer they're still at a point where
only employees are allowed to try the
contact lenses on and they've barely
started the clinical studies that would
need to pass FDA approval speaking of
the FDA they've been surprisingly
supportive of mojo by putting them on a
fast-track program made to get important
life-changing medical devices approved
and out to the public as fast as
possible they've also been able to
partner with a nonprofit that helps
people with blindness and imperative
vision to use as kind of like a ground
zero for testing and tweaking the
contacts and much like neuro-link their
plan is to roll out a version to help
the visually impaired patients first
then they'll be targeting enterprise
customers that would be able to maybe
make their money back from something
like this to justify the high cost that
they'll probably be priced at and then
eventually there'll be a consumer
version for us plebs
damn it there's also a huge concern
about wearing a camera on you that's
connected to the Internet throughout the
day and your potential lack of all
privacy whatsoever an issue that Google
glass face was that people were
concerned about being recorded by the
wearers of the glasses but at least with
Google glass you could tell if someone
was wearing it and as this tech gets
more and more discreet this could pose
an even bigger privacy concern even if
the wearer themselves are comfortable
with the privacy trade-offs mojo is
already keenly aware of these concerns
but there's still a long way to go and a
lot can change and even with all that
being said there's still the valid
question of which if they're able to do
all this in a contact lens what an
improved version of something like
Google glass for using the same micro
components to make it look
indistinguishable from regular glasses
be a faster way to get to market and to
make it more accessible in terms of cost
complexity and battery life
unfortunately I am NOT a scientists so
who knows but what I do know for sure is
that this is insanely cool and drew Mike
Michael Steve Corbin and the entire team
at mojo if you're watching this
put me on the waitlist I am so down
thanks for being part of the watch the
end Club would you wear one of these
yourselves I already said I'm like a
hundred percent down to get neural link
installed in me so like an external
iContact let me know in the comments
below if you are new to this channel I
do video essays like this every single
week going over the best and past
present and future businesses just like
this one so you should definitely
consider subscribing and turning on that
notification bell because it's free and
you can dislike an unsub whenever you
want if you want to support this project
financially you can check on the links
in the video description below
to some awesome products for myself and
my partners that you guys can check out
that is gonna wrap it up for this video
you've been awesome
I've been Jake I'll see you guys in the
next one
[Music]